hey 42 here people have been hiding
treasures for as long as there have been
treasures to hide pirates in particular
were frequent treasure hiders in fact
there are over 3 million shipwrecks on
the ocean floor collectively worth
billions in treasure let's reveal some
of the tastiest and most tangible
treasures you can actually still find
today we start with Forrest Fenn's
hidden treasure coming from Texas Fenn
had been an avid treasure hunter his
whole life after becoming a pilot in the
Air Force in the 1960s he would
regularly fly his plane to Pompeii to
look for valuable artifacts of which he
found plenty fed subsequently earned a
fortune from his uncovered artifacts but
in the 1980s Forrest Fenn was diagnosed
with kidney cancer untold he would only
have a few years left to live so Fenn
decided to put his most valued gold
artifacts into a solid bronze chest the
chest worth $25,000 alone
the treasure it contains is said to be
worth many millions in dollars Fenn hid
the treasure somewhere in the mountains
north of Santa Fay in New Mexico he also
wrote this poem and released it on his
website Fenn says there are nine clues
contained within the poet and that the
clues will lead you directly to the
treasure anyone can go looking for the
treasure and many have tried but to this
day nobody has been able to find it
legend has it that in 1816 a man named
Thomas Beale on the few men he was
travelling with came into a large sum of
gold and silver whilst mining in the
Rocky Mountains the fortune was said to
be worth around 63 million dollars in
today's money with des fortune being so
large bill and his men wanted to make
sure their next of kin would get a cut
of the money after
deaths so bilberry to treasure in a
secret location in Bedford County
Virginia and then wrote three ciphers
the first described the exact location
of the treasure
the second described the contents of the
treasure and the third contained the
names and addresses of the parties next
of kin Beale entrusted a box containing
the free ciphers to a local innkeeper
named Robert Morris and told him in ten
years if Bill did not return for the box
he will be mailed the key to the ciphers
however after 23 years he innkeeper
hadn't had any word or mail from Bill so
with help from a friend they spent the
next 20 years trying to decode the
encrypted cipher texts but they only
managed to decode the second cipher that
contained the contents of the treasure
after Moses death his unnamed friend
published a free ciphers for sale in the
1880s ever since there have been
numerous attempts to decipher the tax
and locate the treasure but all have
resulted in failure the treasure still
remains buried to this day the Oak
Island money pit is different for most
hidden treasures because everyone knows
where it is the problem is actually
getting to the treasure Oak Island is
situated just off the east coast of Nova
Scotia in Canada the story goes that one
day in 1795 an eighteen year old Daniel
McGinnis after observing strange lights
coming from the island went to
investigate at the far end of the
islands he uncovered a circular ground
depression in a clearing of trees and
the tackle block hanging from one of the
branches of a nearby tree Daniel knew
that the island was largely uninhabited
and mostly used by hikers so he
therefore deduced that there must be
treasure at the bottom of the pit he had
stumbles upon his story has inspired
numerous treasure hunters throughout the
centuries to attempt to reach the bottom
of the Oak Island money pit and uncover
its treasures theories as to what lies
at the bottom range from Captain
Blackbeard's treasure to Marie
Antoinette's jewels and Eve in the arc
of the curve
but to this day despite tremendous
efforts nobody has been able to reach
the treasure at the bottom of the pit
this is largely due to a series of
ingenious water traps
there are several cleverly designed
water inlets spanning all away from the
site of the island to the pit at various
depths throughout the pit which will
quickly flood the tunnel with seawater
when the earth inside the pit is
displaced but how do we even know that
there's any treasure at all in the pit
well a group of treasure hunters
assembled a group called the Onslow
company and in the summer of 1804 they
began what would be the third attempt at
uncovering the treasure they made it
down to a depth much deeper than any
previous excavation the group reached 90
feet below the surface and they found
something significant
it wasn't treasure but at 90 feet lay a
stone tablet that looked like this for
decades the tablet was thought to be
garbage it wasn't until the 1860s when
in academic James lychee the professor
of languages at Dalhousie University
successfully decoded the tablet
ciphertext when decoded the tablet reads
40 feet below two million pounds are
buried since the tablet was found at 90
feet
excavators believes that the treasure
lies at a depth of 130 feet there have
been many more excavation attempts since
but all have been foiled by the pits
series of ingenious water traps in fact
six treasure hunters have lost their
lives in the Oak Island money pit to
this day nobody knows who built it or
why and if there is even treasure at the
bottom and it remains one of the
greatest mysteries on earth during World
War two free plundering throughout
Europe the Nazis amassed some of the
greatest treasures the world has ever
known from priceless artworks to
never-ending hoards of diamonds and vast
reserves of gold and the large majority
of it has been missing ever since the
last few days of the second world
it is believed there are reserves have
lost Nazi gold all throughout Europe in
hidden underground bunkers and
shipwrecks however a notable amount of
Nazi gold priceless artworks and over
134 million pounds worth of forged pound
sterling currency was packed into metal
containers than taken on a long hike of
the Austrian Alps to a mountain lake
called Lake top 'lets
and tossed into the lake during the last
dying days of the war numerous dives
have been attempted to recover the
treasure but the lake is hazardous and
there is no oxygen below a depth of 20
metres meaning dives have only been able
to recover a fraction of the treasure it
is rumoured that the majority of the
treasure still lies on the bottom of the
lake if you want to get your hands on
one of the most valuable treasures ever
known to man you will have to get your
diving gear off because it's at the
bottom of the Atlantic Ocean in 1712
Spain assembled one of the richest
treasure fleets to ever grace the oceans
it consisted of 11 ships filled to the
brim with gold silver pearls and jewels
collectively worth over two billion
dollars by today's standards the plan
was to set sail from Cuba just before
hurricane season hit hoping the
hurricane season would deter pirates but
it turned out to be a big mistake just
six days after leaving Cuba the entire
fleet perished at the hands of the
hurricane the treasures and all were
sent to a watery grave
since then seven of the ships have been
recovered just off the east coast of
Florida what experts believe the
recovered ships only contain a fraction
of the massive loot they believe that
the main bulk of the treasure was
contained on the main vessel the San
Miguel and it is yet to be found
thanks for the view subscribe for more
thoughty2